hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well rosemary times
articles asking you know what's the
efforts of care should we buy into this
stuff is this actually a valuable
perspective so what we want to do first
is get down what is the opposition and
Carol Gilligan starts out by contrasting
her work with this guy so how many of
you have heard of the colder one is
anybody else heard of it it's about
moral development it's got 6 a's in it
to ring a bell with anybody they use it
sometimes of education psychology
sociology where else would you want to
maybe in business and in a few other
places Kohlberg postulated that human
beings would go through this levels of
moral development so six five four three
two one six is the highest most people
never make it
that level as a matter of fact hobart in
his actual research said that most human
beings never get past level three or
four it's pretty rare some of the
critics with Colbert get flat that you
know that he's saying everybody gets
through this where we care is going to
be criticizing it is in thinking that
women typically don't get very high so
forward sets out this this scale I'll
put the actual stages bottom one of
those punishments and obedience why do
the right thing because if you don't go
get punished what is what is being a
good person obeying the authorities not
even obeying rules just obeying the
authorities that are telling you what to
do but why is it good keeps you out of
trouble you know am I getting you know
hip face or when you're little kids
Spain or set to your room or y'all that
you don't like something taking money
away from you therefore you're going to
have like a decent human being and now
as soon as you take away the threat of
force what happens with something like
this all hell princes right they will do
just about anything so this is the very
bottom level where people can be
compelled to do the right thing but it's
really iffy it's not going to be very
reliable the second stage he calls
instrumental
and based on this sort of limited
reciprocity I believe it's you and you
will in turn be good to me that's why
I'm will be good I want to be a good boy
because that way I get the rewards I
like getting to go to park candy not
being you know shut out of opportunities
those sorts of things so this is what he
calls the preconventional station why
the preconventional stage well because
this stuff exists before any social
conventions then when we get to level 3
this is a lot of called me good boy nice
girl stage and it has to do with
relationships with maintaining
relationships with social approval with
people saying you're you're a good
person like going to the summer here the
adolescent conforms to prevailing mores
because he or she seeks the approval of
other people so the approvals that the
chief put there so you can see we're
already going through a hierarchy of
goods to write this by the way level 3
and 4 called the conventional stage
because social conventions tell you what
it means to be
we're next girl or nice going good
however you want Frank tells you what
social approval is level fore we get to
what's called the law and order
orientation there are rules you should
follow them because their rules the
adolescent begins to do his or her
duties show respect for authority
maintain the given social order for its
own sake why this is where they become
interested in questions like honor
respect in order to gain that the
inaudible as opposed to a shameful
person we get a little bit higher and we
get to the local contractors level now
we're at we're called post conventional
it's no longer just about what your
society is telling you is expected of
you it's now you as an individual at a
much higher level in this case
contracting with other people and saying
let's all you know work out something
that is mutually agreeable that we can
all settle on usually this is not done
in terms of an explicit agreement where
we all actually get together and say
here is going to be our basic framework
but the idea is you start the asking
well what if what if everybody behaved
this way when society breakdown I should
behave this way so i can keep things
going and that goes beyond the law order
or good way good girl orientations and
then finally we have universal ethical
things like a categorical imperative
clover was very influenced my comment
yeah the basic idea is look when you're
a baby you start out down here nobody is
like born up here that takes time to
development and there's a lot of ways in
which human beings could fail and maybe
never get past this one Kohlberg
interestingly enough a lot of his early
research was done in prisons and what he
found was that not only a lot of the
inmates but actually a lot of the guards
we're at this level and that few other
things that are really interesting that
you found out in order to develop to a
higher level it's not something that
happens naturally and it's not something
that happens just by being in a better
environment or having role models you
actually need been a generally some sort
of conflict to take place and some
people say hey quit acting like a juror
you know here's something better for you
to do you need some sort of clash of
perspectives in order to be able to
carry on the reflection that's required
and probably a lot of you you know
because you're not at this level eater
up at higher levels you had people in
your life and said hey knock it off and
that was important for you the other
things that are important to know about
this is you can't skip stages Kohlberg
things you have to proceed through all
of these and these are hierarchical
these are in a kind of order so some
things are better than others some
things are more compasses so this no
this is an interesting scale I think
bless you I think a lot of people can
kind of get behind this and say yeah no
sense doesn't work here's the key
question that Carol Gillian was
interested does this work equally
formatted for me now
in her experiments of didn't in other
people's experiments did this is where
it gets very controversial we're just
going to let go it out of her cap and
pretend that some of the other stuff
that makes a little bit problematic ISM
isn't there so really you know we're
doing physics we're not going to include
wind resistance we're going to make it
as simple as possible so the problem
that she hose and she was a student
covert pathway is we have to ask
yourself whether the six stages are
indeed universal invariant en
hierarchical we know they are
hierarchical right there they're
arranged in a hierarchy and ordering are
they Universal and invariant that is to
say they're invariant does that mean
that you have to be here before you can
be here before you can be here before
you get me here Kohlberg says that's the
case is that really the case and are
these universities do these really apply
to everybody or is this more aid here's
where she's going to us this is more a
male way of looking at things so
consider this traditionally women have
been more associated with caring with
nurturing with relationships less
associated with the public sphere more
associated with the private domestic
sphere in which those activities would
take place when women are making moral
decisions and these these things are
measuring what we're using to make moral
decisions the criteria by which were
making all decisions are they going to
be more up in here are they going to be
more around here more specifically at
stage three where do our emotions come
we have to sort of leave emotions behind
once we get past early certain emotions
served as X once we get cat stage 3 so
this is the realm we want to
oversimplify it better this is the realm
of emotion this is the realm reason
different hands knees social contractors
have been inferiors universal ethical
principles law and order is inferior to
social contract they're all abstract
rational ways of doing things as opposed
to emotion and concrete relationships
starting to sound a lot like like
Virginia help right we talked about last
class so where are Gilligan's carrying
out this research we are most women
going to end up on this scale probably
here where most men going to end up
here's where she distorted colder than
that Kohlberg never claimed that most
men or even most human beings are
actually up here he says just a very
small sliver actually make it this far
most people are down here what she's
saying who's becomes an exclusively male
well so what is the implication of that
women are less more than that women are
not capable of the same moral
development as men are because you know
they're more emotional they nurturing
and that's going to keep you stuck down
here so Gilligan says this is this may
be an okay scale for format but we need
another scale wooden so she contrasts
the
here's bill again three bucks yeah what
she ended up doing was saying that we
have a phase where there's an
overemphasis on what do you think if
it's correlated to this one of these
people fundamentally about this self
right the self perspective and then it's
sort of like Goldilocks with the three
bears first porridge is too hot that's
what too cold right that is too soft to
hard so if there's an overemphasis on
self what would the overemphasis be or
the second stage you might hang on
society right because that's what Cole
bird is talking about here but what is
this event this isn't the best
assignment this is a bad society this is
about concrete other people the people
that you're in relationships so over
emphasis on others and their needs their
wants their desires what would make them
happy what will make them flourish he
and just like Goldilocks get away from
one extreme shift to another extreme and
then you find the middle position which
is just right yeah this is a proper
emphasis on both cell and so you might
say it this way over emphasis on itself
means on others means neglecting the
self
hey overemphasis on itself means
neglecting others and what they need so
why does it have to go on this way why
couldn't you start out maybe being to
other oriented and then being too soft
oriented and then finding the proper
balance because in general just doesn't
happen Ellie infants are by their very
nature realistic you know they're
they're not they you know little babies
can recognize it another baby gets hurt
and they identify with and start crying
themselves but that's not most of their
experience most of their experience is
wash me feed me play with me look at me
me me me me right so so there is a
primitive early stage and most kids are
like that too whether they're male or
female right kids are pretty demand
those are you have little brothers and
sisters cousins have done babysitting
you know this is the case right there
sometimes like to romanticize children
all the little angels no children angels
not if you let a single one so the idea
is this would be a good scale for male
for female so we would have two
different scales and this whole scale
would emphasize justice this scale over
here would emphasize here first caring
for the self to the exclusion of others
then caring for others to the exclusion
of the self of the sacrifice of the salt
then learning how to balance this
tension and to properly care for the
self and to care for others that's
Gilligan's big point and raw tom tells
you a little bit about you know where
this is coming from theoretically that's
the structure
that's what we're starting she tells you
a few other things too about how they
how they do these tests to figure out
where somebody is on these scales covert
researchers would give you moral
dilemmas and then explain you too they'd
ask you to say what the person ought to
do and then say why and saying why
reveals to you where a person fits on
the scale it would also work that way
with with Gilligan tip why should some
be actively what Gilligan was saying
that kohlberg's researchers were
ignoring was that a lot of women see
moral dilemmas as a narrative of
relationships that extent over time and
that doesn't fit very well into the case
based reasoning that Kohlberg wanted
them to do and she talks about this girl
Amy trying to deal with this moral
dilemma which you guys might be familiar
with a guy's got a sick wife should he
there's different variations she's
breaking to the the drug to the pharmacy
to steal the drug because you can't pay
for it should he just you know steal it
should he do all sorts of other things
it basically has to do it if you're
taking care of another person is it okay
to violate some North some abstract like
property right and this girl Amy who's
taking this big fairly typical says if
she stole it he stole the drug he might
say was would but then if he did he
might have to go to jail and then his
wife might get sick again and he
couldn't get more of the drug and it
might not be good so they should really
talk it out and find some other way to
make the money the researcher said you
can't have it as your answer you have to
earlier with this sort of thing I think
that's right the culper the researchers
said she had to focus on the question
here should I steal the drug alert out
and she started to worry that she wasn't
giving the right answer to the right
question she started hesitate and doing
that places you lower in the scale so
what's going on there she is being
motivated by a different kind of reason
different kind of practical moral
working things out that we call
nationality but one in which it has like
she says here a different ontology
different way of looking at the world as
well as a different ethics now there's
some more stuff in here about you know
object relations theory and Freud and
chemical stage we're going to actually
just skip over that because that's
incredibly controversial and that's not
what Gilligan really wants the base
things on if she wants to be taken
seriously but the basic idea here is
that places the importance of separation
and autonomy for men leads them to
progress on this scale autonomy is you
know being in charge of yourself that
leads up to Center discussions of
morality of our issues of justice
fairness rules and right so that's the
justice perspective the importance of
family and friends for women leads them
to Center discussions of morality around
people's wants needs interests and
aspirations also another where they were
doing their well-being flourishing being
interested in something else as well so
what happens then women are inevitably
going to be seen as less morally
developed from this scale but if you put
terms of this this this offers an
alternative and yell again uses some
some examples of women that she actually
did an experiment with having to talk
about the choice a of abortion or to
carry a baby to term interestingly she
didn't talk about adoption just means
you both in terms of those those two new
ones he talks about how somebody who is
at this very low scale emphasis on self
might say well screw baby I want to do
whatever I want or they might say well
I'm going to have a baby but I want the
baby there to give me long and that's
what I'm going to keep the baby which is
all sort of you know self-paced
reasoning the other oriented thing might
be the woman to say well my my boyfriend
wants me to have this baby all right
only have to think about the baby itself
or you know my parents expect this of me
etc etc the what's really interesting is
the transition from two to three yes
Gilligan calls us the transition from
goodness in a conventional sense with
the day to evaluate truth she says a
woman moves from pleasing others from
being the conventionally dude I we salt
self-sacrificing woman to recognizing
her own needs that's the emphasis
himself he has part of any relationship
so a woman attains moral maturity when
she stops opposing her needs in favor of
others racket recognizing falseness of
this polarity the truth of her and
others interconnections now that doesn't
mean that no everything becomes nicely
nice all the time or something like that
because you don't mean what if she's
what if she stuck in a piece of
relationship that's that's not going to
be a case where her needs and the other
person's needs could actually be
harmonized because the other person
needs for her to be treated right so
proper emphasis on salt and that
accompanied and the relationship or
modify their relationship but in general
this is getting past that self other
duality so yeah but we we notice with
this is there's a polarity between
justice orientation and caring so that's
going to provide us with a basis the
theoretical basis for understanding all
this other stuff for that vixen care
Carol Gilligan is one of really pioneers
of this I think in a lot of respects
with my her work is ready yeah it's not
as good as some of the other writings on
care that they followed us including
pawns discussion